florida's doing a lot florida's really
leading the country in many ways on this
sort of stuff not just on covent but on
the riots too because you know
riots are the they're the real vaccine
riots are the real cure for covid that's
what we learned during the blm riots of
2020
we all have to stay locked in if we even
so much just go outside we're going to
catch this
virus with a 100 chance of killing us
except if you are burning down
minneapolis
then that is actually going to there's a
shield that's going to go around you
and nobody can get covered so it's cool
especially
if you want like a booster you have to
bust into a nike store and steal some
sneakers
that is that's kind of like your that's
like the second shot you get the
sneakers there's no way you can get
covet right
so we're all preparing for more riots
minneapolis totally boarded up other
places in the country are preparing
how's florida preparing they're
preparing by beefing up laws
and figuring out ways to throw rioters
in prison for longer
florida's senate has approved a bill
that was championed by
governor desantis it's an anti-riot law
it permits citizens to sue a local
government
if that government does not stop a riot
it defines a riot as a violent public
disturbance involving three or more
people
acting with common intent resulting in
injury to others
damage to property or the imminent
danger of injury or
damage this law also would grant civil
legal immunity to people who would drive
through
protesters and rioters who are blocking
a road that's a good provision i like
that that's good that's good for law and
order it's good for a stable society
it's good for everybody's rights
this law would prevent people who were
arrested for rioting or offenses
committed during a riot
from getting bailed out of jail until
their first court appearance loves that
love that a lot throw them in jail
throw away that key at least until their
court appearance and this would impose a
six-month mandatory sentence
for battery on a police officer during a
riot love that love that but the left
should love that too right
because they pretend that they're all
for law and order now after the great
horrible insurrection of january 6th
right so love this law think it's
absolutely
phenomenal this is not a down on
people's freedom
that's what the left is going to say
they're taking away our freedom of
expression and our freedom of speech
this is an expansion of freedom of
speech
because rioting is not speech that's not
protected by the first amendment
you have the right to speech you have
the right to peaceably assemble
you don't have the right to burn
buildings down you don't have the right
to threaten people you don't have right
a right to shut down the interstate and
if you do that
you need to be punished so that we get
less of that so we disincentivize that
and so that we punish people who do very
bad things
you're going to hear people say this is
outrageous this is not in keeping with
the
american tradition the anglo-american
tradition so we're not even allowed to
use that phrase anymore
riot acts have a long history in our
political tradition you ever hear the
phrase oh man read them the riot act
oh yeah that guy you know you know what
they're going to do to him they're going
to read them the riot act do you ever
hear that expression that expression
refers to
the riot act an english law back in
1714 when parliament passed the riot act
for much the same reason that we need to
pass the riot act
today down in florida and hopefully
elsewhere around the country
my one real disappointment with the
trump administration
i felt this was just bad instincts or he
was being led by people who did not know
what they were doing
was when he really went all in on the
jailbreak bill and he said you know as
conservatives we need to let a bunch of
criminals out of jail i thought
president trump this is going against
your political instincts this is not the
sort of stuff you've talked about in
your career
this this ain't it chief you've been so
good on so much other stuff
but this ain't it i am glad to see that
governor desantis is bringing us back a
little bit in the direction
of law and order i hope that other
governors
other legislators around the country do
that as well
because we are not going to get any sort
of
real pushback from the squishes on
capitol hill
stop wait wait okay i'm glad i've got
your attention
i need you to like and subscribe you
gotta smash the button do whatever
crazy verb you gotta do you got to do it
because
youtube sometimes doesn't love us
okay and they don't necessarily want to
pump our videos up to the top of your
feed so if you don't want to miss a
video
make sure you like and subscribe right
now
[Music]
[Music]